in this course you will learn how to
improve your JavaScript skills by
building a card game Gavin long teaches
this course Gavin is a freeco camp team
member and popular instructor hi and
welcome I'm Gavin long I've been a
professional software developer for many
years and over the years I've written in
a variety of different programming
languages depending on the relevant
project
c-sharp is my main programming language
but in spite of what your main
programming language may be be a Java
python c-sharp Etc
there is always this one other
programming language that is almost a
mandatory programming language for every
developer to learn that programming
language is of course JavaScript so why
is it so essential to learn JavaScript
well JavaScript is a great language that
can run both on the client and server
side
but it is also along with HTML and CSS a
core technology on the world wide web
according to Wikipedia 98 of websites
use JavaScript on the client's side for
web page Behavior
sure this may change moving forward due
to Technologies like webassembly
which enables developers to leverage
programming languages like for example C
sharp for client-side web Behavior
functionality
but I think it's safe to say that for
the foreseeable future JavaScript is
still going to be the dominant
technology for this client-side where
Behavior functionality so in this video
we'll exercise our JavaScript skills to
create a browser-based basic card game
by going through this video you'll
hopefully learn a few things about
JavaScript HTML CSS and visual studio
code although you'll only create a basic
card game you can use the concepts
you'll learn to create more
sophisticated card games like for
example blackjack or poker so please
feel free to make the application your
own and use the code as the basis for
your own card games at the very least
this video provides you with a great
JavaScript exercise I hope you enjoyed
this video and learn a few things along
the way
so this tutorial demonstrates how to
build a basic card game using vanilla
JavaScript basic CSS and HTML code
this tutorial not only covers creating a
basic card game using JavaScript but
also covers how to create Dynamic user
interactive code using vanilla
JavaScript
we'll cover creating some animation
effects responsive layout design using
CSS grid CSS flexbox and media queries
how to dynamically change the positions
of grid cells so as to randomize the
positions of the cards contained in a
CSS grid using JavaScript local storage
and much more
I would say that the code is accessible
to Learners at most levels I've kept the
code quite simple
if however you get lost at any point the
code can be downloaded from GitHub
please see a link below in the
description to the relevant GitHub
repository
in this video we are going to develop a
basic card game using vanilla JavaScript
I'll use vs code as my code editor even
though I'll develop the game on my Mac
you of course can use vs code for
Windows or Linux and the coding
experience will be very much the same
vs code is of course free open source
software I'll be using the Chrome
browser for testing purposes
so the game that we'll develop is very
basic I've called it hunt the ace
here's a brief description of the game
so we have four different cards one of
which is the Ace of Spades
the user clicks the play game button to
start the game
the cards are flipped over so that the
user can no longer see the face of the
cards our game then randomizes the
positions of the cards so the cards are
in effect shuffled the cards are then
positioned at random locations in a grid
layout each location corresponds to a
random whole number between one and four
the user can then guess where the user
thinks the Ace of Spades is by clicking
on the relevant card
once the user has clicked The Chosen
card the card then flips over and of
course the user is made aware of whether
the user has guessed the correct
position of the Ace of Spades
each game consists of four rounds
in each round the user attempts to guess
the location of the Ace of Spades if the
user fails to guess the position of the
Ace of Spades the user will not be
awarded any points for that round if the
user however guesses the correct
location of the Ace of Spades the user
is awarded points based on the round
number
so yes it's a simple game but I thought
this might be a good JavaScript coding
exercise this code is fairly simple and
therefore this tutorial should be
accessible to a wide audience interested
in programming
if you like this video please hit the
like button for Content like this and
much more please consider subscribing
and please ring the bell so that you'll
be notified of future content please
note that I've included links Below in
the description to additional
information for more detail on certain
Concepts discussed in this tutorial
let's create the project
so let's get started
so all we need to do is open an empty
folder from within Visual Studio code
this folder is of course where our
project files will reside
so I've created a folder which I have
aptly named hunt the ace to house the
files for this project on my computer
let's create three files within Visual
Studio code let's create a file named
index.html of course for our HTML code
let's create a file named index.js of
course for our JavaScript code
let's create a file named style.css of
course for our layout and styling code
our CSS code let's create a folder to
house the images that will be used to
represent our cards as well as a card
that will be used for our game's image
logo
you can download the relevant images
from GitHub at this location
great
the live server extension
let's start by coding basic HTML code
So within Visual Studio code you can
generate boilerplate HTML code for
example the doctype tag that indicates
that we are using HTML5 the HTML tag
head and body tags along with relevant
meta Tags by simply typing in the
exclamation mark character followed by
pressing the Tab Key like this
so I'm going to use semantic HTML to
create a tag named header which will
house header related HTML code in our
layout by semantic HTML I mean the tag
name is descriptive as to the purpose of
the tag rather than for example simply
using a div tag semantic HTML elements
are those that clearly describe their
meaning in a human readable and machine
readable way
so we can type the tag name and then
press the tab key and the code for the
HTML element is generated for us by
Visual Studio code
let's include a div element that
contains a CSS class named header Dash
title Dash container
so a quick way to generate the HTML code
for the relevant tag that includes a
specific class attribute within Visual
Studio code is to type the tag name so
div
then type in a DOT followed by the class
name you wish to include within the
element
then simply press the Tab Key and visual
studio code automatically generates the
desired HTML code
let's include a H1 element for our
game's header
so we want our header to reflect the
name of the game
we are creating so punt the ace
you may be familiar with a visual studio
code extension named live server if
you're not familiar with this extension
it is very useful for monitoring the
effects of changes made to your code
in real time
you can install the live server
extension from this location
so once the live server extension has
been installed we can launch our
application through Visual Studio code
using live Server Like This
we can then tile our code Editor to the
left of our screens and our browser to
the right of our screens and in this way
we can easily monitor the effects of
changes to our code without the need to
refresh the browser window every time we
make a change to our code
so for example let's change our header
text to hunt the Ace of Spades and once
we have saved our code we can
immediately see the effects of our code
change within the browser window
create cards statically with card 3D CSS
effects
so we are first going to create a card
statically then later we'll dynamically
generate the cards through JavaScript
code
we'll appropriately use the document
object model to build our cards and add
them to the Dom document object model
let's first create the card statically
through basic HTML and CSS code
let's create a div tag that contains a
class named card Dash container within
this div tag let's create a child div
element that contains a class named card
within the card div element let's create
a child div element that contains a
class named card Dash inner
within the card Dash in a div element
let's create a child development that
contains a class named card Dash front
let's also create a child development
that contains a class named card Dash
back
let's add an image element as a child
element to the dev element that contains
the class named card Dash front
as you may have guessed this image will
represent the front of the card
so let's assign the image elements
Source tag the path of the image that
depicts the Jack of Clubs
so each card will contain the same back
image
so we can ensure this by adding the
appropriate image element as a child
element to the div tag that contains the
card dashback class like this
so we have built our card statically
using HTML code
as you can see there's not much to look
at at present
so the next step is to style the card
using CSS code so that we can create our
card to look three-dimensional and
create the desired flip effect
our CSS code will create the illusion
that the card is a three-dimensional
object
let's first reference our style.css file
from within the index.html file
I'm not going to go into too much detail
explaining the CSS code because this
tutorial is more about JavaScript
please follow along with the code so
that your CSS code is consistent with
mine
let's create the styling for the cards
Dash container element
by card container element I am of course
referring to the element that contains a
reference to the card Dash container CSS
class
let's create the styling for the card
element
let's create CSS variables to store the
dimensions of our cards
so basically the car dash inner element
contains the child elements card Dash
back and card Dash front the CSS code we
are creating facilitates a flip effect
between the front of the card and the
back of the card
we can test the flip effect by
implementing CSS code so that when we
hover our Mouse pointers over the
relevant card that the flip effect
occurs
so we are writing code so that the inner
Dash card element rotates 180 degrees on
its y-axis when a mouse pointer is
hovered over the relevant card
and we can now test this
excellent
before we create our cards dynamically
through JavaScript code and
appropriately add the cards to the
document object model let's create a
grid for the game area if you like where
the cards will be placed
so firstly let's create four
placeholders denoting the positions of
each of the cards in the gameplay area
so card Dash pause Dash a card Dash
pause Dash B cards Dash pause Dash C and
card Dash pause Dash D
so you can see here in the CSS code I've
given the body element a height of 100
VH this simply means the height of the
body of the HTML document
will take up a hundred percent of the
viewport height of the screen
so I want the gameplay area to be
aligned centrally within the main
element and take up an area based on the
width of the cards
so let's write the code for this
so I'm using flexbox functionality for
the display to centrally align the
gameplay area I.E the area that will
contain our cards
so I'm going to use the calc CSS
function to calculate the width of the
gameplay area
two cards will reside side by side on
each row
the card Dash container style
essentially denotes the gameplay area
then to display the cards in a grid
that will have two cards on each row we
can use the grid functionality provided
in CSS
we can control where each individual
card will reside by allocating each card
position element a position in the grid
by using the grid Dash template Dash
areas property like this
so to get a clear picture of our layout
let's add border styles to the relevant
HTML elements
great
let's give each of the grid cells
different background colors so that we
can get a clear picture of the layout of
the grid
note that each of the four cards used in
this game will be placed in a specific
cell within the grid
great and we can see the grid cells
clearly
so we have now created the grid within
the gameplay area
create cards dynamically through
JavaScript
we have created our cards statically
through HTML and CSS let's create the
cards dynamically using JavaScript let's
go to our index.js file let's create an
array of objects each object within the
array denotes a card or a card
definition each object has an ID
property and an image Path property the
first item is the king of hearts and has
an ID of one the second item is a jack
of clubs and has an ID of two the third
item is the Queen of Diamonds and has an
idea of three
the fourth item is the Ace of Spades and
has an ID of four
let's create a function named create
card of course this function is
responsible for creating a card
dynamically through JavaScript code
firstly let's create a reusable function
responsible for creating a HTML element
let's name this function create element
we can create a HTML element and code
through this line of code
let's use our create element method to
create the div tags that make up a card
so here we can see the static HTML code
that we created earlier to represent a
card
so that we can see what we are creating
here in code dynamically
so basically we have a card element
an inner card element within the card
element a front and back element within
the inner card element
we can use the create element method to
create our image elements
that contain the back card image and the
front card image
let's create a reusable method that adds
a class to a HTML element
let's write code to add the card class
to the card element
let's write a method that adds an ID
to a HTML element so each card will be
assigned a unique ID the ID will come
from the array of card object
definitions that we created earlier
I'll create card method accepts one
argument this argument will be an item
from the card object definitions array
let's write code to add the inner card
class to the inner card element
let's write code to add the appropriate
class to the front dash card element
and the back card element
let's write a reusable method that
assigns a path for the relevant image to
the SRC attribute of an image element
okay before we assign the image path
properties for the card
to the appropriate image elements
let's create a const to store the path
for the image that represents the back
of a card
right let's assign the image paths
appropriately
let's write code to assign the card Dash
image class to the image elements
so now that we have our basic elements
created in code let's assign the child
elements appropriately to their parent
elements so let's create a reusable
method named ADD child element
the code within this method simply adds
the child element passed in as an
argument to the second parameter to the
parent element passed in as an argument
to the first parameter
so let's write code to add the image
elements to their appropriate parent
elements
let's write codes to add the front dash
card element and the back dash card
element to the inner Dash card element
let's write code to add the inner Dash
card element to the card element
let's create a global const and store a
reference to the card Dash container
element
we are not going to add the card
elements directly to this element but we
will use this element constant a bit
later
when we write code to alter the
positions of the grid cells each grid
cell will contain one of our cards the
cells of the grid
are child elements of the card container
element
we are using the CSS grid system for the
grid functionality which represents the
gameplay area I.E where our cards will
be displayed
let's write code to appropriately add
each card element as a child element to
their appropriate grid cell
each grid cell is denoted by a div
element
we are going to map each card to its
initial position by mapping the card
element's ID to the appropriate element
that represents a grid cell
this is how our code will know as it
were which card must be assigned to
which positional parent div element
so let's create a method named add card
to grid cell
let's create a method named Map Card ID
to grid cell
this method will be called within the
add card to grid cell method so if the
card ID is one we want this card to be
added as a child element to the first
position in the grid which is denoted by
a div element with the cart Dash pause
Dash a CSS class
if card ID is 2 we want this card to be
added as a child element to the second
position in the grid which is denoted by
a div element with the card Dash pause
Dash B CSS class
if card ID is three we want this card to
be added as a child element to the third
position in the grid which is denoted by
a div element with the card Dash pause
Dash C CSS class
if card ID is four we want this card to
be added as a child element to the
fourth position in the grid which is
denoted by a div element with the card
Dash pause Dash D CSS class then within
the add card to grid cell method let's
write the code that finds the
appropriate parent element for the child
card element
using the map grid ID to grid cell
method and then adds the childcard
element to its designated parent element
then within the create card method let's
write code to appropriately call the add
card to grid cell method
so let's write a method that will Loop
through each of the objects stored
within the card object definitions array
create the relevant cards and add the
cards to their appropriate grid
positions so let's create a method named
create cards
then all we need to do is write code
that calls the create card method within
the for each Loop that Loops through
each card definition to create the cards
dynamically and add the cards to their
appropriate position within the grid
Let's test the code
okay so we have an issue let's press F12
within our Chrome browsers
and card is not defined okay
and it's because I forgot to include an
appropriate parameter that expects a
card element as an argument within the
map card ID to grid cell method
definition
okay and it's still not adding the cards
to the grid
if we press F12 and inspect the elements
it's definitely adding the cards to the
grid cells
ah but the IMG element is not built
correctly
okay so the code is currently adding the
images to the front and back div
elements whereas the code should be
adding the images to the front and back
image elements so let's fix this issue
oh and I can see that the card Dash
image class is being added to the div
elements rather than the image Elements
which is of course incorrect
this class should be added to the
appropriate image elements not the div
elements
great
so let's modify the CSS code so that the
cards align centrally within the grid
cells
and let's use the CSS flexbox
functionality to align the card
centrally within their parent elements
great
so we have now created our cards
dynamically through JavaScript code and
positioned the cards appropriately
within their grid cells
let's write a method named load game
the method is called when the game is
first launched
so we want our cards to be created
dynamically when the game is first
launched so let's call the create cards
method from within the load game method
let's write a method named start game
this method will be called when a user
clicks a button used for starting a game
the gameplay button if you like
let's go to our HTML file and include a
button element that the user can click
to start the game
let's first write layout related code
for our button
and then let's code the button element
itself
let's write code to create a global
variable that will store a reference to
an array of the card elements
then let's write code to assign the
results of a query for all card elements
to our card's Global array variable
within the load game method
let's write code to wire up a click
event to the start game button element
that we just created within our HTML
code
let's first write code to store a
reference to our start game button
element in a global const
within the load game method let's use
the JavaScript method add event listener
to add a click event handler to the
start game button
when a user clicks the start game button
we want the start game function to be
called
so let's test whether our event listener
is working
great
let's write a definition for a method
that will be called to initialize a new
game
let's write a definition for a method
that will be called when a new round is
started
let's write a definition for a method
that will initialize a new round
let's call the start round method from
within the start game method
so when the user clicks the start game
button
and before the cards are shuffled I.E
their positions are randomized we want
the user to see the cards stacked one on
top of the other and positioned
centrally within the gameplay area I.E
the grid
so to achieve this we are going to first
collapse the grid as it were
the collapse grid functionality simply
involves modifying the grid area
template property so the grid consists
of just one cell
then our code will add the cards to this
one cell
so to achieve this let's first create a
method named collect cards
let's create a constant to store the
grid area template's value that will be
assigned to the grid area templates
property to cause the grid to collapse
as it were
let's create a global constant that
stores the class of the div element that
represents the grid cell
that will be the only cell in the grid
once we modify the grid area templates
property appropriately
so we are choosing the first cell in the
grid to contain our Stacked Cards as it
were
So within the collect cards method let's
call a method named transform grid area
and pass the appropriate Global constant
we have just declared as an argument to
the transform grid area method
let's write the transform grid area
method
so using the card container LM element
that contains the grid cells this
element has been designated through
appropriate CSS code as our grid
let's change its grid template areas
property through implementing the
appropriate JavaScript code like this
then let's write a method to add the
cards to the cell that at this point
takes up the entire grid
so the grid now consists of only one
cell
let's call our add cards to grid area
cell method from within the collect
cards method
let's call the collect cards method from
within the start round method Let's test
the code
excellent
so before the shuffle cards process
begins we want to flip the cards
so that the backs of the cards are
facing the user
so firstly let's update the CSS code so
that when the inner card div element
also contains a card named flipit that
the UI responds by rotating the card on
its y-axis by 180 degrees I.E the
flipped class being present in the
relevant cards in a card element results
in the card flipping from front to back
as it were
so let's go to our JavaScript code and
create a method named flip cards this
method contains one parameter
if the card is on its front and the flip
to back argument is true our code will
flip the card so that its back is facing
the user
so let's create a method named flip card
this method accepts two arguments the
first argument will store the relevant
card element the second argument will
contain the Boolean flip to back value
so as we know at this stage the inner
card element is the element that is used
for creating the flip effect
so the inner element is the first child
contained within the card element
so we can use the relevant card elements
first child property to reference the
inner card element
the logic for this method is as follows
if the flip to back argument is true and
the inner card element doesn't contain
the flipped class then add the flippet
class to the inner card element
so if the card is already back facing we
don't want to flip the card so that it
is front-facing
flip to back is true so we want the card
to have its back facing the user else if
the inner card element contains the flip
it class
we want to remove it
the result of this will mean that the
card is flipped so that the card's front
is facing the user if the card is
already facing front side up it will not
contain the flipped class
which is what we want in this case
within the flipped cards method let's
call the flip card method appropriately
so that all cards are traversed and
flipped as it were if appropriate
let's use the JavaScript set timeout
method so that each card is flipped at a
different time this is done just to
create a simple animation effect
so each flip will occur
at an interval measured in milliseconds
which will be the index a sequential
value from one to four incremented with
each iteration of the loop multiplied by
100. so let's call the flip cards method
from within the start round method after
the collect cards method we want the
cards flipped on their backs so the flip
to back argument passed to the flip
cards method is set to true
Let's test the code
excellent
so now we want to randomize the
positions of the cards so let's create a
method named shuffle cards
we are going to use JavaScript set
interval method to run a function that
we'll create in a bit named Shuffle
so every 12 milliseconds the shuffle
method will execute
let's use a variable named Shuffle count
to count the amount of times the shuffle
method
is called
when the shuffle count variable is equal
to 500
we can use javascript's Clear interval
method to stop the shuffle method being
called
the shuffle count variable is
incremented every time the shuffle
function is called
we are going to create a method to
randomize the positions of the cards
within the shuffle function let's call a
method named randomize card positions
right so let's write the randomized card
positions method
so let's use javascript's math.random
functionality appropriately so that we
generate a random whole number between 1
and 4.
we want two random numbers generated
let's create a global variable that
stores an array of card positions within
the grid
then we can use these two random numbers
to swap the position values for the
relevant cards within the card positions
array
this creates a shuffle-like effect for
our four cards
this randomized card positions method
will continuously be called until the
clear interval JavaScript method is
executed
from within the shuffle method
at this point the positions of the cards
should be unpredictable to the user
okay let's write a method named
initialize card positions that contains
the code to store the initial positions
of the cards in the grid
the gameplay area
within the card positions array
let's call the initialize card positions
method from within the create card
method so each initial position of the
card is established when the game is
first loaded through the relevant card
elements ID
I want to create a method named deal
cards that will execute when Shuffle
count equals 500. and therefore the deal
cards method will be called after the
shuffling or randomization of the card
positions is complete
the deal cards method will in effect
restore the grid to contain four grid
cells and add each card back to their
original positions in the grid
the div elements that make up the grid
I.E the grid cells will then have their
positions within the grid altered in
accordance with the random positions
stored in the card positions array this
randomization of their positions
was of course caused through the
randomization functionality executed
within the randomized card positions
method
so let's create the deal cards method
let's create a method named add cards to
appropriate so
within this method let's call the add
card to grid cell method and pass in
each card element
to the add card to grid cell method
within a loop that traverses all of the
card elements
from within the deal cards method let's
call the add cards to appropriate self
method
so this will in effect restore the grid
back to its original state with four
cells and each cell containing a card
element
the grid cells will at this point be in
their original order
so now let's call a method named return
grid areas mapped to card pause this
method will return a grid area template
value
containing a new positional
configuration of the grid cells based on
the randomized positions now stored in
the card positions array
this randomization of positions was
caused through the execution of the
randomized card positions method called
from within the shuffle method
let's create the return grid areas
mapped to codpos method
this method simply generates a grid area
template that contains a new position
configuration for the cells in the grid
based on the random positions generated
through our Shuffle functionality stored
within the card positions array
we can then transform the grid as it
were to change the positions of the grid
cells by assigning the grid the new grid
area template value returned from The
Returned grid areas mapped to card parse
method
note that I'm using the back tick
characters to envelop the value returned
from the return grid areas mapped to
codpos method
these characters allow us to interpolate
a string by appropriately using the
dollar symbol and curly brackets to wrap
the relevant variables
I've included a link in the description
for more detail on string interpolation
in JavaScript
let's comment out the call to the flip
cards method so that we can see if the
positions of the cards are being
randomized by our Shuffle functionality
great
let's uncomment the call to the flip
cards method
so let's first remove all the borders
and let's also remove the background
colors from the grid cells and see what
our game looks like
great
okay so let's create functionality so
that when a user makes a choice and
clicks on the back of the card that the
user believes to be the Ace of Spades
that the card that is chosen flips to
the front and the user is made aware of
whether the user's choice is correct or
not
if the user's choice is correct the user
is awarded points depending on the
relevant round number
if the user's choice is incorrect the
user is awarded no points
so we are now going to write the code
that executes as a result of the user
making a choice as to the card that the
user believes to be the Ace of Spades
let's first create a method named choose
card
let's create a method named can choose
card which will be called from within
the choose card method
there are certain states that the game
will be in where we don't want the user
to click on the back of the cards for
example when the cards are being
shuffled
so we don't want the choose card
functionality executed while the shuffle
process is in motion as it were
so they can choose card method will
return a Boolean value to the calling
code to indicate to the calling code as
to whether the game is in the right
state where the choose card
functionality can run
this expression is basically saying that
if the game is in process and the
shuffling process is not in progress and
the cards are not in the process of
being revealed
the expression returns true
when the expression returns true the
user is able to choose a card
when the expression returns false the
functionality in the choose card method
will not be executed if a card is
clicked
let's declare and initialize the
variables involved in the expression
we'll set the relevant values for these
variables appropriately as we develop
the game
the next functionality we want to
express in code is the evaluation
functionality so the code we are about
to write evaluates the user's choice so
let's write a method named evaluate card
choice
this method is responsible for
evaluating whether the card that the
user chooses is the Ace of Spades or not
so let's first declare a global const
and set its value to the ID of the Ace
of Spades which is four
let's write an if statement in order to
evaluate whether the ID of the chosen
card is equal to the ID of the Ace of
Spades in both cases we want to Output
appropriate feedback to the user
if the user's choice is correct we also
want to update the score appropriately
we'll write the code for the update
score method in a bit
so let's write a reusable method to
Output feedback to the user so if the
user hits the target as it were
outputs an appropriate message for a
winning Choice else output an
appropriate message for a losing choice
let's declare a global const that
references the current status element
this is the element that is updated with
status information dynamically through
our code at appropriate points during a
game
so let's go to our HTML code and create
the current status element
if the user guesses the correct card we
want to Output text in a green color if
the user guesses an incorrect card we
want to Output text in a red color
let's create a method named update
status element
at times we only want to make the
current status element visible or
invisible without updating the relevant
elements text
so if the calling code passes in only
two arguments we can set the display
appropriately however if the calling
code passes in more than two arguments
this indicates that the calling code
wishes to update the text of the
relevant element
and possibly update the color of the
element 2. so this is a technique that
we can use in JavaScript for method
overloading
and of course the choose card method and
the evaluate card method must include a
card parameter
so let's write the code for the update
score method the update score method
calls the calculate score method the
calculate score method discovers as it
were the number of points to add to the
user's score through a call to the
calculate score to add method
the number of points to add to the score
depends on the round number
so if the round num variable is 1 add
100 points if the round num variable is
2 add 50 points if the round num
variable is 3 add 25 points else add 10
points
let's declare and initialize three
Global variables round num Max rounds
although I think this should in fact be
a const
and score
in the initialize new game method let's
set score to zero
round num to zero and Shuffle in
progress to false
in the initialized new round method
let's increment the round nump variable
by 1.
let's disable the gameplay button let's
set the game and progress variable to
true
and let's set the card's revealed
variable to false
if you are not sure about the purpose of
all these variables at the moment this
will become clear as we develop the game
so when around is started we want to
update the status of the game in Black
text let's call the update status
element and pass in the text shuffling
dot dot dot
when a new round Begins the first thing
that happens is the cards are shuffled
let's go to our HTML file and add those
elements responsible for outputting the
score
and round number to the user I'm also
including a logo image for the game in
the same row as the score and round
elements which is just a stylistic
choice
let's create a global const to store the
container element for the score
let's create a global const to store the
score element
let's create a global const to store the
container element for the round element
let's create a global const to store the
round element
when a new game is started we want to
make the score and round container
elements visible
and we want to update the score and
round elements with the appropriate
values
when a new round is started we want to
update the round element appropriately
when a card is chosen by the user we
want the relevant card to flip to the
front so let's call the flip card method
from within the choose card method
then three seconds later we want all of
the cards to be revealed to the user so
that the user can see where the Ace of
Spades is if the user did not guess
where the Ace of Spades was correctly
so we are using javascript's set timeout
method to ensure that all the cards are
flipped front side up
three thousand milliseconds or three
seconds after the user makes a guess
so in order for the choose card method
to be executed in response to a user
clicking the back of a card we need to
attach an appropriate event listener to
each card element
let's use javascript's add event
listener method to ensure that our
choose card method is called whenever a
card is clicked
let's run the code
so don't worry about the layout I know
the game logo here is huge we'll address
the layout and styling issues a little
bit later
okay there seems to be a bug let's
investigate
so the issue here is that I've referred
to round
as opposed to the correct variable name
which is round num so this is an easy
fix
so I need to make a few further
modifications to the code to ensure that
the choose card functionality works as
expected
we need to set the shuffle and progress
variable to false at this point in the
code IE this code executes once the
shuffle process is completed
at this point we also want appropriate
output text shown to the user
let's run the code
great
so
to complete the choose card
functionality we need to execute
appropriate code that tests to see if
the final round the fourth round has
been reached by the user
so let's write a method named end round
so let's use the set timeout function to
ensure that if the game is not yet over
that the next round begins in three
seconds or if the game is over that
appropriate output text is presented to
the user and a new round is not started
so if the maximum round has been reached
it's game over all rounds of the game
have completed
let's write a method named game over so
when it's game over we want the score
and the round number to be hidden and an
appropriate game over output message to
be displayed to the user notice how we
are enveloping the relevant output in
bactic characters
the backtech characters allow us to
include what is known as template
literals in our JavaScript code
if you'd like to read more about
template literals please see an
appropriate link that I've included
Below in the description
let's run the code
okay I guessed where the Ace of Spades
is correctly but the score hasn't been
updated
so let's update the code so that when
the score changes the score element
reflects this to the user
excellent
so when the game is first loaded we
don't want the score and the round
number elements displayed to the user so
let's update the code accordingly
great
so we have pretty much completed the
mechanics if you like for our game but
the layout and style certainly needs
attention so let's split our screen so
that we can see our code editor next to
our browser window let's go to our CSS
file
so let's update the header element so
that the display is flex and the flex
direction is set to column this
positions its child elements one on top
of the other as opposed to the default
Direction which presents the elements
next to each other on the same row
and let's give the margin bottom
property a value of 10 pixels
let's style the header Dash title Dash
container element and use the flexbox
CSS functionality to Center our heading
text
great
so let's use the flexgrid functionality
for the display of the header Dash round
Dash info Dash container element
so that the image logo the score the
round number are spaced evenly on the
same row
we'll see the effect of this styling
code a little bit later
so let's give all elements contained
within the header Dash round Dash info
Dash container element a width of 150
pixels
so let's horizontally and vertically
Center all of the elements contained
within these elements by using the
flexbox functionality
so that Ace of Spades image you are
currently seeing is of course way too
big so let's give it a height of 75
pixels
great
let's round the corners of the image
logo by setting its border radius
property appropriately let's add in a
border
great
and let's give the image a box shadow
excellent
lastly let's rotate the image minus
three degrees
great
that looks pretty good
let's add some color related variables
to our CSS file
let's style the badge class
so that our score and round number text
stands out
excellent
that play button really needs to be
styled so let's go to this URL where we
have a selection of button styles to
choose from
I like this one so let's press the
relevant button to copy the relevant CSS
style code to our clipboards let's paste
the code into our style.css file
and update the code appropriately so
that the relevant code relates to our
play game button
great
I want to use a particular Google font
for this application
so let's go to this URL here and let's
copy the sample code for importing a
font into our application from within
our CSS stylesheet file
then let's appropriately update the
relevant import code
so that we are importing the quicksand
font
let's create a variable to reference the
relevant font family value
let's set the font family property of
our body element to the variable that we
have just created
great
let's make the font size for the current
status element bigger
great
let's align the text for the current
status element centrally
great
the first animation I'd like to create
is the shuffle animation
at the moment during the shuffle process
the cards are stacked one on top of the
other and are motionless let's create
the illusion through our Shuffle
animation that the cards are literally
being shuffled
let's create a method named animate
Shuffle that contains a parameter
a numeric argument will be passed to
this parameter which will be a numeric
value that is incremented for every time
the shuffle function is called
let's create code to generate two random
numbers between one and four
let's reference two cards of our four
cards randomly through the two random
numbers that we are generating in this
method
then we can modify the positions of the
cards and the relevant card elements Z
index properties through code like this
the mod function represented by the
percentage character that I'm using in
the first if statement
means that when the result of the
shuffle count value divided by 4 does
not have a remainder then code will
execute to toggle the shuffle left class
for the relevant card element
the mod function I'm using in the second
if statement
means that when the result of the
shuffle count value divided by 10 does
not have a remainder then code will
execute to toggle the shuffle right
class for the relevant card element
the card elements are of course selected
by our code at random this will create
the illusion that the computer is
shuffling the cards
let's write the code that calls the
animate Shuffle method from within the
shuffle method
let's create the CSS code for the
shuffle left class
and the shuffle right class
and you can see that we are simply
altering the positions of the cards
through the shuffle left class and the
shuffle right class
you can of course play around with the
various settings related to the shuffle
animation until you are happy with the
animation effect
once shuffling is completed we want to
make sure that none of the card elements
contain the shuffle left clasp or the
shuffle right class
and that shuffle effect is not happening
right so the reason is we need to
include transition code for our card
elements in the CSS file like this
and I think that is a pretty good
Shuffle effect but please play around
with the relevant values and see if you
can create an even better Shuffle effect
the next animation effect that I want to
create is for when the game is first
loaded I want the cards to fly in from
the top left hand side of the screen to
their positions on the grid let's create
a CSS class named flyian
that will position the card elements
appropriately off screen
when the fly-in class is removed through
our JavaScript code the card will move
to its original position on the grid
which ultimately results in a sort of
fire and effect
let's create a method named cardfly and
effect
that removes the fly in class from the
card elements add controlled time
intervals we are using the JavaScript
set interval method to call the fly-in
method at a predefined interval
then we are further controlling when the
fly and class is removed from the
relevant card element
through the use of an if statement
we want to fly an effect
to be executed when our game is first
launched so let's call the fly and
effect method from within the load game
method
let's add code so that the fly in CSS
class is added to each card when each
card is first created so to do this we
can call code to add the fly and CSS
class to the card element from within
the create card method
excellent the last animation effect I'd
like to create is I want the gameplay
button to not be visible when the game
first loads but then slowly fade in once
the fly-in animation effect has
completed
let's include keyframe functionality
within our CSS file that controls the
opacity of the relevant element
let's then add this animation to our
play game button element like this
let's initialize the gameplay button to
be invisible when the game is first
launched
then let's set its display CSS property
to inline block after the fly and
animation effect completes
great but I want the height of the
container to be static so let's set the
height of the gameplay button container
element within our CSS file
I've also given this element a set width
excellent
so I've created our game so that it
looks pretty good on desktop screens but
what does our game look like on smaller
screens like for example what would our
game look like on an iPhone 12
it looks pretty good as it is on smaller
screens because we are using CSS flexbox
and grid functionality for the layout of
our game
but we could improve our layout for
smaller screens so to make our
application layout responsive for
smaller screens let's include an
appropriate media query within our CSS
file
so we want certain CSS classes to be
dynamically modified in response to a
smaller screen size
so let's say that when our screen size
is 600 pixels or less
we want our layout to respond in a
certain way
at this smaller screen size we can for
example make our cards smaller like this
we can also adapt our card container
element to respond appropriately to
smaller screens with code like this
let's make the height of the main
element a bit smaller
let's make the current status element a
bit smaller
let's make the gameplay button a bit
smaller
and let's also make our game logo image
a bit smaller
let's check the responsiveness of our
application through our Chrome browsers
excellent
so our game is pretty much complete but
I'd like to include functionality so
that if a user closes the browser for
some reason before the user has
completed a game that the user is able
to resume the same game
when the game is launched at a later
point in time
the way we are able to create this
functionality is by using local storage
this allows us to persist data to our
browser
through our JavaScript code when the
browser is closed the data stored in
local storage is not lost and can't be
retrieved from local storage through
JavaScript code at a later time when the
relevant game or application is launched
in the user's browser so firstly let's
write a few reusable methods to abstract
common local storage related
functionality
so let's create a method named get
serialized object as Json
so we are going to persist an object to
local storage in Json format
so when we pass an object to this method
it will return a string value in Json
format that represents the object passed
into this method
we will then be able to save the return
to string to local storage
let's create a method named get object
from Json
when we read the Json formatted string
from local storage
we are going to want to convert the Json
string back into a JavaScript object
so that we can use the object in our
JavaScript code
let's create a method named update local
storage this method saves a key value
pair to local storage
you can see the first parameter is the
key which is the unique identifier for
the value that will be passed into the
second parameter which will of course be
a string in Json format representing a
JavaScript object let's create a method
named remove local storage item
this method of course is used for
removing a local storage item
let's write a method named update game
object the object that we are going to
persist to local storage contains the
score and the round number pertaining to
the relevant game this method can be
used to update the relevant game object
the game object object where the score
and the round number will be stored will
have Global scope
then let's create a method that will
handle saving the game object to local
storage
let's create a unique key
to identify an incomplete game in local
storage
let's create a method named check for
incomplete game the this method checks
local storage for a unique key
if the relevant key exists in local
storage that means the user has data for
an incomplete game saved to local
storage
oops I forgot to create a helper method
let's create a method that returns a
value
from local storage based on the key
argument passed into this method
if the relevant local storage item
exists
we want to ask the user if the user
wishes to continue with the relevant
unfinished game
so we are going to use the confirm
JavaScript dialog for this purpose
if the user presses the OK button
then our code will update the game with
the score and round number from the
previous incomplete game saved to local
storage else the score and round number
will be initialized to zero which means
the user has chosen to start a new game
so let's call the check for incomplete
game method from within the initialize
new game method
let's write the code that saves the data
pertaining to a game after the user has
selected a card
Let's test the code
excellent
if you liked this video please hit the
like button and please feel free to
share this video with anyone you feel
May benefit from its content
for Content like this and much more
please consider subscribing and please
ring the bell so that you'll be notified
of future content
the code created in this tutorial can be
downloaded from GitHub please see the
URL for the relevant GitHub repository
Below in the description thank you and
take care